-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
We're back in the studio,
and now we are going to
get to the news.
Tomorrow will mark the end
of the first year
of President Biden's time
in office,
so, buddy, you got like 24 hours
to make something happen.
You got to cancel student debt
or bring back "Lost"
or something.
I mean, even MSNBC
is struggling with headlines.
[ Laughter ]
The House committee
investigating the Capitol attack
issued a subpoena yesterday
to Rudy Giuliani,
though really all you have to do
to make Rudy appear
is draw a pentagram on the floor
with Maalox.
[ Laughter ]
The Biden administration
announced a plan today
to give Americans
hundreds of millions
of high-quality,
medical-grade face masks.
They're just doing that now?
[ Laughter ]
What are they sending out next,
sourdough starter?
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the Biden administration
will distribute hundreds of
millions of high-quality masks
through pharmacies
like Walgreens and CVS.
Unfortunately,
they're behind the razors,
and the one guy with the key
is on lunch break.
[ Laughter ]
A White House official told CNN
that the distribution
of 400 million free N95 masks
next week is, quote,
"the largest deployment
of personal protective equipment
in U.S. history,"
besides, of course,
the week that freshmen
head off to college.
[ Laughter ]
Democratic Louisiana Senate
candidate Gary Chambers
released a new campaign ad
yesterday
about legalizing marijuana
that appears to show him
smoking a blunt.
"He's got my vote," said people
who will forget to vote.
[ Laughter ]
Walmart is reportedly planning
to create its own NFTs.
And if you want to laugh, ask
one of their greeters about it.
Arrghh!
[ Laughter ]
"I have no idea where that is!
Maybe try sporting goods?"
[ Laughter ]
The cost for an annual Citi Bike
membership in New York
will increase next week by $6.
So to get their money's worth,
riders will have to start
throwing an additional bike
into the Hudson every week.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
19% of adults are participating
in so-called dry January,
which is what your girlfriend
experiences
when you show her
your Wordle score.
[ Laughter ]
Did it feel like 3% better
than we thought?
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the Red Cross
will offer blood donors
a chance to win tickets
to the Super Bowl
if they donate this month.
And for many donors, this could
be their only chance to go.
And that --
It's a joke about the Jets.
That was the monologue,
everybody!